[Musique]
mais on débat sur france 24 elle veut
incarner une nouvelle margaret thatcher
et elle doit affronter une crise
énergétique économique et social les
strauss va devenir la nouvelle première
ministre du royaume uni l emporter face
à son rival ancien ministre des finances
richy sounac auprès des 170 mille
membres du parti conservateur
l'ancien ministre des affaires
étrangères de boris johnson défend la
dérégulation la baisse des impôts
l'envoi des migrants clandestins au
rwanda et elle veut se débarrasser de
tout ce qui reste en matière de
législation européenne post briques site
alors sera t-elle la nouvelle dame de
fer comment fera t elle face à une crise
énergétique économique et sociale sans
précédent
alors que des élections se profilent en
2024 un retour de boris johnson est il
possible on en débat avec mes invités
j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés
philippe teurs le bon soir philippe
chroniqueur je le fais à france24
chroniqueur international
franco-britannique de surcroît bienvenue
à vous en face de vous qui a pris de
mathieu bonsoir économiste à l ofce et
le spécialiste du royaume uni bienvenue
avoue sophie loussouarn est avec nous
bonsoir professeur de civilisation
britannique à l'université de picardie
hauteur de briques site annexe aftermath
et c'est aux éditions de bloomsbury
bienvenue à vous de nice mcshane est en
face de vous bonsoir vous êtes ancien
ministre travailliste des affaires
européennes bienvenue à vous et
bienvenue à vous bien sûr en plus à
paris vous êtes avec nous ce soir issu
d'une famille de gauche liste ross et
bien c'est une femme politique chevronné
qui a occupé de nombreux postes
ministériels dans le gouvernement de
cameron mais est aussi bien sur boris
johnson son portrait avec olivier fait
seul et marque beaucoup
fumée blanche a down in street liste
ross devient premier ministre après
avoir mené la course en tête elle sera
la troisième femme à exercer ses
fonctions dans l'histoire du royaume uni
pourtant il ya quelques mois encore
allaités mal connu du grand public mais
l'actuel ministre des affaires
étrangères a réussi à convaincre les
quelques 200000 militants du parti
conservateur
l'espèce a réussi à s'imposer comme la
candidate de droite du parti
c'est un peu plus d'un tiers des députés
conservateurs est prêt à soutenir le
candidat le plus à droite qui allait
figurer sur le bulletin de vote et 10 13
s'est imposé comme sa candidate et a
réussi à construire une coalition d'ong
arrivés seconds du vote des députés elle
a en revanche bénéficié d'un plus grand
soutien des électeurs que richie sounac
les stress a séduit la base du parti
avec une image plus populaires et
authentique que son rival ancien
banquier d'affaires puis ministre des
finances présenté comme la digne
héritière de margaret thatcher
passive faire face à la flambée des prix
au royaume uni
pour ces dix prochaines années
audacieuse de l'offre
d'énergie
âgé de 47 ans liste rose fait ses
premiers pas en politique en 2010 en
tant que député puis a gravi rapidement
les échelons au sein du parti
conservateur
quatre ans plus tard david cameron la
nomme secrétaire d'état à
l'environnement en 2016 elle devient
secrétaire d'état à la justice sous
theresa may elle cumule depuis les
postes à responsabilités au point de
devenir la ministre des affaires
étrangères de boris johnson en septembre
dernier un premier ministre truculent
dont les frasques ont entraîné la chute
le style de la nouvelle locataire de
downing street devrait en revanche être
plus sobre ce fait le soir d'un style
plus sobre que celui de boris johnson
oui c'est cet homme intègre honnête
efficace shiuan studio ne l'est pas et
est là
la confiance des membres du parti
conservateur notamment les populistes
qui ont
élus boris johnson en décembre 2019 par
ailleurs elle veut baisser
considérablement les impôts ce qui
risque de créer une spirale
inflationniste
et puis elle veut déréglementé réduire
la taille de l'état comme le faisait
margaret thatcher dans les années 80 on
va l'écouter c'était juste après qu'elle
a su qu'elle était élu
y ont failli merci de m'avoir accordé
votre confiance pour diriger notre grand
parti conservateur le meilleur parti au
monde on a un avion et en tant que
leader j'ai l'intention d'honorer les
engagements que nous avons fait aux
électeurs à travers le pays
des snacks chaîne le meilleur parti
conservateur du monde sait ce qu'elle
dit c'est à des derniers parti
conservateur du bonhomme et les
républicains ne faut pas grand-chose ici
les autres partis conservateurs d'europe
l'italie l'espagne
sont dans un mauvais n'est
pas conservateur ok ok cool co haguenau
c'est un trait saussez le derrière l'un
passé deux mois pour flatter les bons
activistes les militants du parti
conservateur qui est absolument normal
maintenant elle doit adresser en et les
autres 65 millions d habitants en
angleterre qui font face ce soir demain
pour l'année à venir des défis des
problèmes jamais vu depuis un siècle
donc ça va cela crée des liens à voir
avec bad touch de tous ces trucs faux
scoop un réseau mais on va y revenir un
flip talent fois rappelé effectivement
c'est moins de 1% de la population qui
finalement a élu liste reste puisque
c'est moins deux cent mille membres de
ce parti conservateur et elle devient l
première ministre donc c'est vrai que
c'est un système particulier si les
britanniques alors on est donc système
parlementaire la chef d'état c'est là
mais c'est le parti qui gouverne de
partie des élus qu'une grande majorité
de 81 sièges en fin 2019 pour une
période de cinq ans donc il doit y avoir
des élections
législatives en grande-bretagne avant
janvier 2025 donc les sauces en courant
qui peut-on pour gouverner mais elle a
parlé cinq ans que boris vian ce nom ait
pu avoir si les types a poussé à la
pause par les ses propres amis dans le
parti conservateur le problème pour les
strass c'est que alors que les militants
de base ont voté en faveur d'elle les
membres élus du parti conservateur était
plutôt en faveur de russie nak
et donc est là elle hérite une partie
qui est déjà
divisés entre ceux qu'ils auraient
souhaité richie sounac ceux qui
préfèrent les strauss et ceux qui
regrettent boris johnson qui aurait bien
aimé que paul chénereau vienne et depuis
le début de cette campagne qui a duré
quand même deux mois qui est très long
huit semaines il n'y a pas eu de
propositions il n'y a pas eu d'annoncé
les gens savent parce qu'il va se passer
boris johnson était complètement aux
abonnés absents pendant toute cette
période et manon se trouve dans une
situation où les gens des factures à
payer comme disait tennis mais qui ne
savent pas comment ils vont se joindre
les deux bouts dans les mois qui
viennent il attend avec hâte les
annonces de deux les choses mais on va
constituer son gouvernement mercredi
c'est ça oui elle a dit dans les jours
qui viennent avant une avant la fin de
la semaine elle annonce soit quelque
chose qui va aider les gens à payer les
factures un quatrième était alors c'est
vrai qu'elle fait campagne justement en
utilisant le nom de margaret thatcher
née en mettant d'ailleurs en s'habillant
comme elle en prenant des postures très
cette chaire yens alors c'est vrai que
dennis mcshane disait ça n'a rien à voir
avec margaret thatcher sauf que
effectivement le contexte économique et
social on voit là il ya eu des grèves
tout l'été les éboueurs les cheminots
les chauffeurs de bus et j'en passe les
dockers par exemple au port de félix top
14 mille employés de train qui prévoit
de s'arrêter ce mois ci ça rappelle
quand même ses terres juste avant
justement là l'arrivée de margaret
thatcher oui c'est vrai mais quand il se
rase a fait sa campagne elle a vraiment
fait une campagne comme si elle ne
voyait pas tout ce qui se passait dans
le pays en matière effectivement demont
des tensions sociales et elle a vraiment
axé sur sa campagne sur le fait qu'elle
serait une margaret thatcher qu'elle
mènerait une politique de l'offre
qu'elle baisserait des impôts qu'elle ne
mettrait pas du tout en place de mesures
de soutien aux ménages qui sont très
frappé par la hausse des prix d'énergie
elle a même rappelé que quand gordon
brown ancien chancelier de l'échiquier
travailliste avait il faut soutenir il
l'avait dit au milieu de l'été les
ménages britanniques à soignies france a
dit je ne ferai pas du tout de
d'économie à la garde un gala gordon
brown je continuerai sur main sur ma
perspective individuelle et au quand
même au cours du temps elle a entendu
elle a fini par entendre des voix en
particulier de son rival régis unac qui
lui disait attention il y a vraiment une
crise des prix de l'énergie qui est là
il va falloir soutenir les ménages sinon
les conservateurs vont perdre les
prochaines élections qui sont bientôt en
fait un 2024 c'est pratiquement demain
ça va être justement l'enjeu on va
écouter margaret thatcher on a retrouvé
quelques images
d'archivés gueule soyons bien clairs la
stratégie conservatrice pour l'emploi
consiste à réduire les coûts de
production
c'est ce que nous avons vu sur le
terrain non ce n'est pas une grève aux
états unis c'est empêcher les autres par
la force d'accomplir ce qu'ils ont le
droit de faire right to do on rappelle
des souvenirs de ce match est libre a
été le plus jeune président du syndicat
des journalistes en angleterre dans les
années soixante dix et j'ai organisé des
grèves immeubles verts stoppés tu les
nouvelles sur le bbc pendant 24 heures
j'ai pas vraiment j'ai autant joué de
l'annoncé sais rien moi madame h ab
raison y avait des noms sur les mots des
mineurs
[Musique]
les souletins train des milliers contre
elle ces greffes aujourd'hui c'est 24
heures à petit délai dans les livraisons
c'est rien à voir on a aboli tu les
droits des travailleurs la plus des
syndiqués c'est comme en france n'était
que ben ali ce que je connais des
personnes
allaient être une le marteau sur les
droits syndicaux ya plus de droits
syndicaux dont vous pouvez pas faire la
comparaison vous entre cette époque et
les grèves de cet été ça passe pour les
militants du parti conservateur âge
moyen 65 70 qui ont un vision lorieux de
l'héroïne mark thatcher mais pour mes
enfants va t elle trop tel est lé de
l'histoire comme queen victoria
aussi une chose c'est que les strauss à
l'époque c'était quelqu'un qui était
ont-ils facture elle est ali militer
contre thatcher dans les années 80
protestataires à août et elle a
complètement changé de registre l'été
libéral démocrate elle a changé pour
devenir conservateur elle était contre
la monarchie a volé l'abolition de la
monarchie complètement et qu'on devine
république on a changé de fusil d'épaulé
maintenant ce n'est plus le cas elle
était pour rester langues européennes
donc contre le break si tu es b
finalement elle a changé de 10 dès
maintenant elle n'a pas de colonne
vertébrale donc on dit bon elle est un
peu commun à quelqu'un qui change avec
levon qui qui souffle est sûre c'est
vrai qu'il ya une question de viabilité
dans la lah les décisions que les strass
fort capable de prendre et est-ce
qu'elle l'a même pendant la compagne a
complètement changé d'idée et sow les
aides il faut apporter les ménages 1
donc ça laisse quelques doutes sur sa
capacité de mener à bien sa politique
elle sera confrontée à une situation
très difficile la plus difficile sans
doute depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
de nombreux défis non seulement des
défis économiques mais des défis
géopolitiques des défis constitutionnel
les défis géopolitiques la situation en
ukraine et elle devra se placer dans le
sillage de boris johnson qui était très
populaire en ukraine mais des défis
constitutionnel avec les causses on l a
attaqué ni kloster jeunes en disant que
c'était eux chelsea que quelqu'un qui
cherchait à attirer l'attention c'était
très maladroit de sa part n'est cluster
jeune qui veut organiser toujours son
référendum sur l'indépendance en écosse
et puis la question évidemment de
l'irlande du nord elle veut renégocier
le protocole l'irlande du nord elle
devra changer sa politique ou alors elle
s'attire affluence est dans la veine de
maury johnson oui oui
mais à l'envers elle s'attire al
mécontentement de tous les chefs d'état
européens
catherine mathieu justement pour en
revenir sur l'économie des facteurs des
factures d'énergie d'après ce que jl
vont carrément doublé et je lis aussi
qu'un quart des habitants du royaume uni
se prépare à ne pas allumer le chauffage
cet hiver
oui parce qu'en fait il ya un mode de
fixation des prix de l'énergie au
royaume uni qui est de laisser des prix
de l'énergie évolué aux consommateurs
comme les prix sur les marchés du gaz et
comme vous le savez des prix du gaz ont
beaucoup augmenté au cours des derniers
mois donc ce qu'on annonce même ce même
c'est plutôt un triplement de la facture
de gaz et d'électricité des ménages donc
une situation très difficile et
effectivement on pourra avoir jusqu'à la
moitié de la population qui serait en
pauvreté en précarité énergétique
si rien n'est fait pour changer ce
dispositif
à l'annoncé des annonces et il faut être
un jour madame tracé exact bon je refuse
tuchan je refuse le plan de gordon brown
je refuse de copier le président macro
mais ce matin la une du times elle
balaie les prix des denrées lepreau la
politique du parti travailliste pt
c'est ce que voulait dire un kabyle oui
parce qu'en fait elle a après est là
elle a au cours de l'été comme je le
disais tout à l'heure à intégrer les
remarques on y faisait y compris dans
les camp conservateur sur sa position
très dure vis-à-vis des prix de
l'énergie et puis aussi depuis plusieurs
jours celui qui va sans doute être son
chancelier de l'échiquier croisic
warthog discute avec des industries de
l'énergie pour changer avec elle le mode
de fixation de prix du gaz effectivement
sa prochaine un système qui serait
plutôt un système de bouclier tarifaire
ça veut dire que pour les ménages il y
aurait sans doute moins de hausse des
prix à venir mais pour l'état il
faudrait subventionné aussi les nerfs
j'te viande savoureuse
pragmatique sans doute par rapport à à
ce qui se passe à la crise qui est la
chose de vous étonner dans ce match on
revient tu parlais du logis covilis donc
elle est pragmatique
elle est assez pragmatique elle veut
réussir elle a des filles énorme c'est
pas le prix de l'activité roi des
courses et tout ce qu'il faut comme ici
aux fausses pour protéger les foyers à
mon avis c'est gagner l'élection de deux
ont elles pour ça on ne peut pas face à
avec une politique de donald trump assez
droitiste ya pas d impôts à réduire en
angleterre on le donne des pétroles
eplace des pinceaux ou pauvre bat
l'ombre à rachel et d'eau parce que n'a
pas des dons this temps important de
paix dans son discours aujourd'hui
strauss avait quelque chose de très
important elle a fait un discours très
court quand elle a été continue des
résultats de l'élection et elle a dit
qu'elle baisserait des impôts qu'elle
prendre en compte la prise crise des
prix de l'énergie mais elle a aussi
ajouté qu'elle s'occuperait du nhs donc
elle a bien pris en compte le fait
qu'ils aient besoin aussi solaire
simples
passants ont réduit seront des hommes
donc elle va augmenter le parc sur les
militaires 3% du mip jamais entendu en
europe depuis qu'ils ont mis des
défenses 1 déjà des fonds spa donc ça on
ne peut pas faire son augmentation
massive des impôts elle dit tous et
d'importer croire à partir de demain
elle doit prendre de vraies décisions
pas de blabla devant son parti elle dit
qu'elle est prête à creuser des déficits
publics en danse altenrhein richy sounac
accusé d'ailleurs les strauss d'avoir
une politique économique fantaisistes et
en effet on voit mal comment elle peut
réduire l'impôt sur les sociétés ou
l'impôt sur le revenu sans créer une
spirale inflationniste
de toute façon les taux d'intérêt vont
augmenter et le problème crucial ce sera
d'équilibrer les comptes publics comment
peut-elle
réformer le système de santé réformer
l'éducation
apporter davantage de subventions aux
services publics en diminuant les impôts
philippe taris dans une situation où
l'inflation augmente je vous donne un
peu de défilés gens il ya des agences
qui sont la peau et des légions concert
ils ont conservé leurs factures qui
raconte que les gens leur téléphone et
ils leur disent qu'ils sont terrifiés
par l'idée que leurs factures vont
arriver dans la boîte aux lettres parce
que cette facture qui était à
1007 son livre peu près de 1000 euros
par an jusqu'à maintenant voir monter à
3500 à partir du 1er mai prochaine ça
ira jusqu'à 5700 et bois 6000 euros par
an qui peut pays ça et ça c'est pour les
particuliers quand il s'agit des
entreprises et a pas de bouclier fiscal
n'y a rien donc les entreprises voient
leurs charges d'électricité augmenter
augmenter et vous passez de
spirale qui pour augmenter de 10 fois le
prix normal et donc les entreprises
testent en chauffe on vire du monde et
on mange pas où on chauffe pas et encore
la session actuelle mais on peut pas
faire les deux ont payé 90 mille livres
blancs les face à une facture d'un
million 3 s'est pas passé grand palais
son historique avec manu katché
fascinant elle a hélas vrai très élévé
ou pas elle est vrai tout de même cette
comparaison est question de ressources
ou balzac l'on sait les trente
glorieuses
outre libéralisme l'air de l'argent très
bon marché le batteur très bon marché
les produits chinois très bon marché
tout était relativement l'énergie très
bon marché maintenant cette trempe
lorieux outre libéralisme est révolue
s'est terminée la peau les traces mais
c'est une femme intelligente je suis
d'accord avec les autres elle doit
commencer un nouvel erp dépôt de ces
décisions c'est soit elle va les
appliquer pour nos sept sa guise au ou
bien elle passe le bateau aux
travaillistes a tant besoin lors des
élections elle doit dire à ses militants
suivez moi on peut gagner les élections
suivent importe qui on le sait le
gouvernement de continuation de lit
d'origine forestière et on est foutu
terminé
lui conseille également de ne pas
s'entourer des proches de bird johnson
mais d'élargir son gouvernement a alors
voir d'immenses
conservateur le défi pour elle ce sera
de gouverner avec un parti conservateur
très divisée entre les partisans de
richy sounac et ses partisans à elle
terminé ses amis pas des partisans déçus
dax était d'hommes autorise chaque passe
itunes sa vie jusqu'à l'âge de 44 ans
s'est mise vendredi en déviant
milliardaire les plus hauts d'héritière
le plus riche de la en fallait des
favoris au début
ça brille dans les sondages excusez moi
si cela n'arrive jamais une chose m'a
dit qu'elle restera sept bris
conservateur elle a tourné sa veste
plusieurs choses c'est très typique beau
dans l'histoire du parti conservateur et
maintenant elle doit proposition très
difficile et franches mais il doit
parler à la nation pas au lit âgées du
parti conservateur dans les chaises
rulon c'est ça qui est le défi ya un
autre défi
mercredi elle va être face à ce qui est
en mon nom la chambre des communes pour
la premi à questions du parlement et
voilà qu'en sd font face à au chef du
parti travailliste qui lui et qui
connaît très bien son rôle qui connaît
très bien les rouages qui vont mener
très bien les questions à poser et c'est
très bien comme embarrassé le premier
ministre je pense qu'il va y aller à
coeur du joie parce qu'il sait en même
temps que le parti travailliste depuis
quelques mois depuis même un long et
mène dans les sondages et donc c'est
bien élections anticipées aujourd'hui
c'est tout le défi pour l'histoire c'est
c'est chaud que c'est les travaillistes
qui gagnerait à elle et les
conservateurs seront finis ir fatigue
saut là l'état n'est pas le cas dans
deux ans les animaux le logo du parti
conservateur aura été au pouvoir pendant
14 ans il faut jamais oublier le parti
conservateur est au pouvoir depuis 2010
lorsque dvcam elle a remporté les
élections
et bien sûrs sur le parti conservateur
qui était exercée bay pas tu les
frasques de position sur son départ en
l'irritation du peuple vis-à-vis de ce
qui s'est passé parce que finalement les
gens se disent faire on nous a pris pour
des idiots parce qu'on nous a infligé
des règles et les gens qui gouvernent
les suivait pas
le portugais était autres donc donc il
faut changer quelque chose dont clic
frontistes ont repris dans la popularité
dans les sondages et donc je pense que
maintenant ce qui est homme donc le
patron du parti travailliste il va
peut-être voir ce moment qui va arriver
on va y revenir mais n'y a pas tout de
même beaucoup de charisme non plus c'est
un peu la chance de liste de tromper
vous l'aï local du tourisme pas le
charisme pollution mais là plus je pense
que l'esturgeon va on va revenir à cette
bataille avec les travaillistes et avant
ça voudrait on parle de la politique
étrangère que va mener ali strauss liste
rose qui a refusé au revoir quand même
ses relations avec la france je vous
montrais un peu cette passe d'armes qui
a fait beaucoup réagir la semaine
dernière liste rose qui avait refusé de
répondre quand on lui a demandé si
emmanuel macron était son ami ou son
ennemi et emmanuel macron qui lui a
répondu alors qu'il était en déplacement
en herbe en algérie on va écouter cette
passe d'armes presse demain macron amis
ou ennemis
le jury est sorti
mais si je deviens première ministre je
le jugerai sur des actes et non sur des
paroles je lui dis le peuple britannique
la nation
qui est le royaume uni est une nation
amie
forte et alliés quelles que soient ses
dirigeants et parfois malgré eux au delà
de ses dirigeants ou des petites erreurs
qu'ils peuvent faire dans des propos
d'estrade si on n'est pas capable entre
français et britanniques de dire si on
est amis ou ennemis
le terme n'est pas neutre
on va vers de sérieux problèmes entre
temps il l'a félicité il a dit qu'il
était prêt à travailler entre alliés
amis c'est ce qu'a dit emmanuel macron
en deathmatch et oui ya qu un filou
c'était juste une posture
président mcrory aujourdh'ui bon ça
c'est finalement en français le brume
1,2 des bacs ce décès pas un pourtour cd
fumel et que les cubains dont les
premiers coups mais comme il n'a pas
fait mon réseau sauf que le new times le
journal national plus important du monde
dans le monde anglo saxon un article
papier très critique sur le manque de
crédibilité de l'estrade sur le bandit
qu'étrangères bizzbee les états unis
avaient causé que les os et les anti
européens depuis cette eau est peut être
devient plus européen d'ordre cet homme
qui sait à l'eau mais elle n'est pas
préparée et des rues britanniques
je vais faire un ennemi ou pas on a mis
le président au bail dunn et washington
est un ennemi ou carrément nommé et un
deuil ce qu'elle a dit ça aussi des
états unis elle a dit qu on lui a posé
la question
qu'est-ce qui vous procédez président je
veux pas passer des commentaires sur les
intervalles thierry merret sa politique
assure l'élue du nord qui va se déchirer
le traité entre l'objet et le moyen
l'union européenne est très mal reçue
par bail qui dit à tout le monde je suis
et un orgueil je suis artiste you est
aussi au congrès américain et bakr ou en
attelage ursula politique de boris
johnson non non non non non le boris
toujours il considère ce dernier dix
cochons des communes disait c'est ici
churchill reste est tout prêt le plus
près possible que les américains église
a vraiment été ministre et étrangers
pour l'eau des zones à b aucune
expérience et papa de sensibilité
l'étranger et pour pour un chef de la
diplomatie britannique
elle a fait preuve de beaucoup de
maladresse et c'était vraiment
lamentable de critiquer le grand allié
militaire du royaume uni qu'est la
france vous jamais oublier c'est
justement ça vous a j'ai trouvé ça
choquant oui moi je pense que philippe
elle doit se montrer forte face à la
france face à l'union européenne pour
défendre sa position vis-à-vis du bric
site le problème c'est que c'est
maladroit parce que elle est en transe
offusqué le poste de maquereau qui a
fait comme une réponse intelligente
environ un conte bretagne est toujours
notre ami qui que ce soit au pouvoir on
est amis et on est pareils mieux quelque
chose dans ce sont là
macron c'est un européen je pense qu'il
est agacé et déçu que la grande bretagne
soit partie avec le break site vous avez
en face les strass qui est devenu un
brick city très dur et donc évidemment
elle défend sa position là où ça clashe
c'est vrai avec les romans que vis-à-vis
de baden et les états unis on n'a pas eu
ces tacots mirobolants camp 30 toujours
depuis de break c'est avec les états
unis on n'a pas d'accord non plus avec
la chine on n'a pas vraiment de bons
accords avec l'inde il est vrai que elle
elle doit faire bouger ce globe britton
dont on a tellement entendu parler mais
qui a du plomb dans l aile et c'est vrai
que quand on parle des états unis il est
vrai que jeff bridges et 13 à gaza
béchio britanniques vis-à-vis du
traitement de les rondes avec le brésil
on n'est pas prêt vraiment aller très
vite dans le bon sens oui oui j'aimerais
dire je pense protocole pour moi a dit
strauss a vraiment suivi la même ligne
que celle de boris johnson elle le dit
de façon plus franche mais en fait elle
souhaite que ce protocole soit revu il
ya une législation qui va peut-être être
voté au royaume uni ou pas ce qui est
très étonnant c'est que quand ils
stressent a été nommé ministre des
affaires étrangères on s'est dit du côté
de l'union européenne comme elle était
aux avant 2016 en faveur du maintien du
royaume uni dans l'union européenne elle
aura une position plus souple dans les
discussions avec l'union européenne en
particulier sur le protocole nord
irlandais et s'est avéré que non elle va
elle a pris une ligne très dur et c'est
ça qui nous étonne je pense encore
toujours du côté de l'union européenne
on s'attendait à pouvoir discuter plus
facilement avec elle et on voit depuis
plusieurs jours les déclarations qui se
suivent des autorités européennes
jusqu'aujourd'hui ursula von der leyen
qui felicity strauss d'être à la tête du
parti conservateur et qui espère qu'il y
aura des relations qui vont s'améliorer
mais on se demande comment ça peut se
faire puisque en fait elle s'est pas du
tout positionné sur ce jeu mala et sur
l'aspect de la global brittan liste ross
tout de même a réussi quelques points
forts un accord avec le japon le
commerce en vue de lui non plus mais
quand elle est trop tôt quand le royaume
uni a quitté d'une européenne justement
l'épée d'une europe anisé vous
n'arriverez pas à répliquer tous ces
accords de façon
elle a réussi à le faire
[Musique]
reste la nouvelle-zélande est là le
royaume uni maintenant a fait acte de
candidature pour faire partie de
l'accord trans pacifique et se
positionne bien sûr des questions
justement des changes mondiaux de
services donc je pense que quand même là
il ya quelque chose qui se dessine du
côté britannique oui mais il est vrai
que lorsqu'elle était ministre du
commerce extérieur elle a scellé environ
56 accords avec des pays étrangers et
c'est là qu'elle s'est révélée
excessivement efficace ll était elle à
voyager dans tous les pays du monde
essentiellement en asie mais également
en australie au canada et elle a renoué
les liens très forts qui unissent et le
royaume uni avec les pays du
commonwealth donc plus efficace que
maurice est
les plus énergétiques de johnson soleil
zakho des commerces est purement copié
collé collé donc il n'y a rien de
nouveau il parlera sa politique a nui
non pour il ne s'adresse pas dans ça le
avec lui au piano simplement copiés d
accord que l'union européenne a eu avec
avec ces pays là edit ah c'est notre
version britannique c'est identique
seule exception c l'australie on laisse
entrer tout l'agneau et boeuf produits
sains génétiquement modifiées avec les
rebelles quiero furax chaque fermier à
tout le monde de l'agriculture en
angleterre qui va voir leur profession
un outil pas là le boeuf et l'agneau
très bon marché modifiées génétiquement
d'australie ça elle va avoir vrai
problème persuadé le board apicole de
voter au sein de deux ans il ya aussi la
question de l'ecosse parce que quand on
a évoqué comme ce fait a dit tout à
l'heure il y a eu cette
remise à plat de la premier ministre
écossaise n'est que le stage
rappelez vous que les choses étaient lus
avec 160 mille voix n'est que le stage
d'été a été élu avec plus d'un million
de voix les strass dit un brin écolo
stage qu'on ne l'écoutent plus qu'on la
snob
de toute manière qu'elle souhaitait à
réponse donnée kloster jaune ça va pas
se passer comme ça je suis là premier
ministre écossaise et je veux toujours
un deuxième référendum sur
l'indépendance de l'écossé le bras de
fer va se poursuivre les bonnes faveurs
continuer c'était très maladroit de les
strass de parler donné que le stage de
cette manière parce que ça ne va jamais
s'améliorer entre ces deux personnes et
c'est très mal parti le premier jour de
l'arrivée de l'estrie se disent
d'herning suspension en vue sauf il aux
formes la politique de l'immigration
tout de même faudrait elle veut
poursuivre cette politique de renvoi des
migrants illégaux vers le rwanda a parlé
oui ici elle a été rejetée par le
tribunal cette politique mais elle
compte manifestement la remettre en
place oui elle veut lutter contre
l'immigration illégale et cela ce
n'était pas lui une ligne de fracture
entre richy sounac et les strauss les
candidats du parti conservateur était
uni pour lutter contre l'immigration
illégale y compris avec cette politique
il veut convoyer
au rwanda alors évidemment il y aura un
bras de fer là dessus avec puisque c'est
une violation du droit international
parce que chaque fois qu'il ya un
immigré doit partir ben les avocats
interviennent ils annulent nous vole
donc jusqu'à aujourd'hui geo personne
est portée aux
mêmes choses parce que y aussi reçoit
pas mal d immigré illégal non envoyée à
mi mandat et six mois plus tard le conte
est évident ils sont tous rentrés chez
eux en allant vers israël c'est une
blague
sociaux démocrates danois l'ont toujours
essayer ça ne marche pas c'est guy pic
ségatier la menace est de renvoyer toute
la barre il est évident pour empêcher
quelques auliac avec ses pauvres
syrienne où je sais pas qui est arrivée
sur les plages de douves c'est une
blague et c'est un problème jusqu'à
maintenant avec johnson ces dernières
s'identifient le président on le tourne
à gauche et à droite l'ordre alors pas
du tout politique stable on l'avait
l'échec bad mais les chèques cadeaux de
barcelone moi je veux pour mon pays que
bas des traces or ici c'est peu mais
elle ne peut pas le faire on le répète
au simplement laisse le goal du daily
telegraph qui est élu maire qui plaira
ces activistes très âgées un sonneur
cannes dans le parti conservateur mais
comment peut-elle le faire surtout elle
doit restaurer l'image du premier
ministre qui a été ternie par boris
johnson au moment du patch et cates et
elle doit rétablir l'image d'honnêteté
qui qui qui a été entaché par boris
johnson et ensuite elle doit s'appliquer
à unir la nation qui est quand même très
divisé et faire donner l'image de
stabilité dans cette période de crise
économique sociale et géopolitique
boris johnson justement puisqu'on parle
de lui un retour est-il possible on va
le revoir seulement à voir ces images ce
tout dernier discours à la chambre des
communes
philippe il peut revenir boris johnson
on entend dire qu'en coulisse que
finalement il a soutenu ni strauss parce
qu'il pensait que liszt rush n'aurait
pas la colonne vertébrale suffisantes
pour faire face aux défis économiques et
que lui reviendrait ça c'est faux
possible je pense qu'il a soutenu liste
soit ceci parce que régis unac a
démissionné pour forcer des pins de
position contre le traître alors une
rancune entre ces deux hommes est-ce qui
peut revenir éventuellement et peut
revenir est-ce qu'il doit revenir saumon
pas à il faut laisser le champ libre à
lille strauss ii de faire le travail il
faut surtout pas qu'elle fasse ce
travail dans l'ombre de bolt soupçonne
qu'ils s'ajustent à ses côtés où qu'ils
soient derrière en train de saboter ou
de lui donner des idées ou des
instructions il faut une opposition
disparaisse de la scène politique il a
uni la boue mais c'est pas habilités il
a beaucoup de possibilités il peut faire
ça
non ici il ya des propositions pour des
circuits pour donner des discos et
gagnant beaucoup plus d'argent qui n'a
gagné que quand il était premier
ministre il peut revenez de re devenir
journaliste yves et gagnera beaucoup
plus d'argent qui est la gagne et que
l'on reste que c'est l'argent s'ils
recherchent donc non mais c'est très
important et en même temps rien
n'empêche personne de retourner chercher
un rôle politique plus tard pour le
moment il faut qu'il faut qu'il dégage
il faut que laisser le champ libre à
leicester
en plus chaud devenir président de la
france que bolton se bat contre est
entré dans la politique prix de d'excès
les eaux maintenant vont se refermer et
là une bonne carrière pas mal premier
ministre quand même ah voilà il a coiffé
sa démission n'aurait plus l'ambition de
revenir
non je pose parc c'était très mauvaise
d'éviter aux chocs des communes ces
communicateurs amusant peu coluche un
peu exagéré bcd jamais un homme de
chambre des communes et donc à je crois
qu'à calais ce passage des semaines à
louis à les chercheurs et créent ces
mêmes mois il peut qu'aller beaucoup
d'enjeux il faudra choisir l'autre
carrière plisson sa fille le soir sur la
commission des privilèges de la chambre
des communes va examiner le panty gates
et si c'est vrai visage effectivement
parce qu'on l'a si cette commission
trouve qu'il a menti il pourrait même
perdre son siège de député et donc
devoir quitter quelles sont les
probabilités qu'il politique piège c'est
assez dense et assez sérieuses et si
sérieux parce que c'est une partie
totalement
bipartite ou tripartite s'est pas
contrôlé par l'opposition il ya des
conservateurs de dos et ils ont botté en
l'île inhabitée et à examiner le cas
parce qu il a le droit de dire une
vérité à la chambre des communes mais
elle est l'obligation de corriger le
genre après john steed a franchement
donné à bras d'honneur au parlement et
les députés tous confondus n'aime pas
être traité je parle en connaissance de
cause avec un tel mépris donc là si les
dix effectivement il a appelé à
démissionner c'est sur cette
circonscription s'est terminée ça c'est
le discrédit parce que le discrédit
total ce qu'il restera très populaire
dans une partie de la population
britannique il faut pas oublier qu'il a
remporté les élections en 2019 avec la
plus grande majorité qeu décret sénateur
prince johnson au nombre de marina zone
il reste très populaire aujourd'hui et
je ne pense pas qu'il sera prêt à
quitter la scène politique et il
continuera selon moi toujours à
intervenir dans le débat et il faut pas
oublier que dans les élections de 2010 9
il avait réussi à faire venir auprès des
conservateurs des électeurs
travaillistes du nord de l'angleterre
sur des problématiques sociales sur des
problématiques d'investissements publics
d'infrastructures et je pense que ça il
ne sera pas prêt de c'est et ils
risquent d'être up en fait encombrant
pour l'is trust parce que s'il
intervient dans la presse s'il
intervient dans les médias je pense que
ce qui sait ce qu'il a à faire il aura
une influence nécessairement sur la
réussite économique menée au royal
espagnol je peux simplement une petite
intervention est aussi à des pitchs le
tue la partie de nos auteurs de
terre-pleins des dénonciations
rougissent mineurs eux ils ont tous deux
toujours botté en europe anti-immigrés
angels à incarner ça en plus
nou lé parti travailliste lui à
d'horribles qu'un cadeau pas imaginable
c'est jeremy combine les gambettes
georges marchais contre je sais pas
sarkozy au
maquereau ces deux là monsieur de choix
c'est impossible pour josi de pub mais
la difficulté est que il a une siège
avec un majorité mince
donc si il reste à sion ducobu qui est
possible il va perdre 7 sièges à la
prochaine élection
donc est ce qu il veut avoir cette
humiliation au départ en disant comme
tony blair a fait j'ai fait mon devoir
je vous fais mon meilleur je donnais un
grand parti grand majorité allaient
strasbourg chose à l oi je prend le
large na dépannage donc c'est mais pas
sur les patients alors justement il nous
reste 5 minutes est-ce que les
travaillistes vont revenir au pouvoir
c'est un petit peu ça aussi la question
qu'on se pose sophie loussouarn donc on
parlait de ces élections dans deux ans
élections législatives mais alors ce qui
est étonnant tout de même c'est on
parlait du charisme de carthame comment
se fait-il alors qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui ils ont le vent en poupe
comment se fait-il qu effectivement il
ya un plafond de verre où est-ce qu'ils
vont réussir à faire passer le jeu ne
change ce qui est aura du mal à unir le
parti travailliste qui est divisée entre
les partisans de jeremy cobain et aucun
n'a atteint 10 en deux d'une gauche
centristes toujours admirative de tony
blair et ceux qui le stum et peu
charismatique et il a du mal à rallier
l'ensemble des travaillistes mais cela
dit le parti travailliste a au moins dix
points d'avancé sur le parti
conservateur
aujourd'hui et a proposé le gel des prix
de l'énergie une mesure qui coûterait
100 milliards de livres qui évidemment
très populaire parmi une partie de la
population britannique qui aura à faire
le choix entre se chauffer et se nourrir
cet hiver
mois par les philip earl sera justement
recours possible ou pas des
travaillistes
a eu raison on a eu deux eric robin donc
c'était un cadeau inestimable
proposition this way la face à dieu même
temps il a toujours ses adeptes si je
comprends qu'il ya toujours ses adeptes
dans le parti travailliste john bico
been reported on maintenant ce qui est
cet homme qui qui il faut le dire quand
même il put droit dans ses bottes il est
plus intelligent il y plus
charismatiques même beaucoup moins
charismatique bruce thompson mais je
pense plus charismatique que les strauss
on verra bien ce sera peut-être à
égalité il a peut-être un mot ils voient
peut-être à sa chance venir mais c'est
pas facile parce qu'il a quand même deux
ans à tenir face à l'izk cross élite
chasse elle va faire tout en son pouvoir
pour augmenter ses chances ont gagné les
élections en 2024 il va gagner avance
mais peut-être qu'il a plus de chances
maintenant avec les phrases de pollution
de ce nécessaire de devoir son jour
arriver que si pollution s'arrêter un
premier ministre un exemplaire sans
jamais mettre un pied en dehors de la
ligue droits l'usure la loi peut-être eu
beaucoup plus office surtout je pense
qu'aujourd'hui aussi bien le parti
conservateur que le parti travailliste
sont très divisés et on voit bien que
dans les grèves qui ont lieu au royaume
uni car starmer est très en retrait et
dit à ses proches surtout ne soutenez
pas les piquet de grève il va y avoir le
coup du parti travailliste dans quelques
semaines comment ça va se passer avec la
base du parti travailliste alors qu'il a
eu très très peu de soutien de la part
de pierre starmer et de ses proches
dennis mitchell bon écoutez c'est
difficile je suis du parti j'ai assisté
à des piquets de grève nous une prose ou
tony blair a lâché les poches aussi
djaoui copine je viens de rédiger les
journaux et je me suis monsieur se prend
dix ans comme les deux fois j'étais
jeune j'ai remis non on est toujours
dans les partis de la gauche des
divisions le droit de gaucher son
importance quand le parti et troupes à
gauche oui impossible de faire élire un
requin paria à françois hollande sur les
fraudeurs chez le ps et regarder les ps
aujourd'hui donc pour le parti
travailliste a eu ce week-end passé le
parti travailliste est bosselée
touristes partis cette course aux oies
dimanche le lendemain 4 pouces ont donc
et ça ça passe ça fait très volatile
aaron at-il star main annonce est pâle
excité c'est vrai est peut-être ce
quelqu'un très calme il fait pas défaut
qui est vu comme honnête direct qualifié
comme avocat et cetera c'est une bonne
loi parce que les oppositions gagnerait
ramon les élections c'est le
gouvernement que les perles et sexy
carrément alice traces qu on ne sait pas
est ce qu'un fait des erreurs nécessaire
pour laisser entrer les partis
travaillistes c'est fort possible
un bain je vous assure je peux jouer on
a alors on a eu assez peu harry potter
l'époque ben à l'époque les tories ce
personnel est touchée
avec le torchon facile de gagner les
élections contre les terroristes des
années de 1,90 y aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est beaucoup plus
difficile mais former un gouvernement
majoritaire chez nous avec les êtres
c'est parce que les causes étaient
passés totalement au dacia lis donc le
formation s'est passé va gagner elle
vient beaucoup plus européen avec des
nécessités de la coalition des
arrangements des gouvernements en
minorité
merci en tout cas c'est pas gagné pour
les travaillistes dans deux ans malgré
tout on n'a plus le temps merci beaucoup
sophie loussouarn ans elle choisit son
gouvernement et voilà donc ce sera
mercredi merci ce qu'il vous soit merci
beaucoup de distractions et merci
catherine mathieu merci fils et philippe
torl et puis merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis vous restez avec nous sur
france24 bien sûr
[Musique]